for decades intel was the king of
semiconductors their performance was
unmatched and consumers were proud to
have an intel powered machine
even five years ago intel maintained
much of the same dominance as they
simply had no competition but with time
it seems like intel brand power and
market share are just being eroded away
year after year
meanwhile their competitors are doing
better than ever before
amd has been consistently posting
all-time high market share and nvidia
nearly reached a trillion dollar
evaluation not to mention it we've been
experiencing the biggest chip shortage
of all time over the past two years so
if intel was ever going to get back on
track it was during the past two years
but into has been struggling to even
fully recover
in fact intel is still down 37 from the
dot-com high which was set 22 years ago
in that same time period amd has grown
3x and nvidia has grown 70x
and if you needed any more confirmation
that investors have no faith in intel
you just have to take one look at their
p ratio which currently sits at 7.35
for perspective even toyota has a pe
ratio above 10 and toyota isn't the
slow-moving automotive industry not the
semiconductor industry so what happened
to intel
one of intel's first missteps was
missing out on the mobile market in the
late 2000s and early 2010s smartphones
were just starting to gain popularity
and contrary to popular belief intel was
actually on top of this
in fact they started development of a
chip called the atom in 2004 which was
specifically designed for small internet
connected devices
and the first adam chip called the
silver throne came out soon after the
first iphone in 2008 but while intel did
realize the potential of small devices
they vastly underestimated the potential
of smartphones
you see it when apple was developing the
iphone they actually approached intel
and asked them to be their chip provider
intel would spend some time doing volume
cost and revenue projections but
unfortunately intel would turn down
apple thinking that producing chips for
the iphone wouldn't be worth the effort
clearly intel vastly underestimated the
popularity of the iphone and intel's
former ceo paul otelini was actually
super upfront about the shortcoming he
stated quote in hindsight the forecasted
cost was wrong and the volume was 100x
what anyone thought
while it's great that paul was able to
acknowledge their shortcoming this
doesn't change the fact that intel not
only missed out on apple but all of the
major smartphone manufacturers from
samsung and xiaomi to oppo and huawei
and this gave qualcomm the perfect
opportunity to step in it and dominate
the sector intel would eventually come
around to this market and they would get
the adam chip into smartphones even from
samsung and the lg but intel never
became the primary chip provider for any
of these companies not just because they
were late but because they didn't
produce arm architecture chips
if you're not familiar with or market
your chips these are basically the
standard within the mobile industry the
key difference between arm chips and
intel chips is their power draw arm
chips are specifically designed to be as
power efficient as possible while intel
chips are generally optimized to offer
as much performance as possible intel
took a gamble with performance over
efficiency and this was definitely the
wrong move given that 95 smartphones are
powered with arm-based chips today intel
tried to hang on as long as possible but
they would eventually give up in 2016
after losing a major contract
while intel had decisively lost out on
the smartphone chip market they did spot
one more opportunity within the mobile
market and that was 5g modems
intel was actually rather early to this
market and they were even in talks with
apple to become their primary 5g modem
producer
but the problem was that apple was not
entertaining intel's offer because intel
was their top choice but because they
had issues with qualcomm and
unfortunately for intel apple and
qualcomm sell their differences right
before intel's partnership was about to
begin
intel could have tried to compete
against qualcomm but they didn't really
want to do this so they would end up
selling their 5g modem business to apple
for 1 billion dollars and before you
knew it into had missed out on their
first wave of smartphones the second
wave of smartphones and the race towards
5g
aside from missing out big on the
smartphone market intel would also face
serious competition within their core
market from none other than amd
this was definitely something that intel
did not see coming from their
perspective they had won the desktop
market they had loads of deals all over
the place even including apple but this
would all change when a woman named lisa
sue joined amd in 2012. lisa knew that
intel had a massive lead in terms of
technology not to mention amd was nearly
bankrupt so the only way amd could catch
up was by risking it all and that's
exactly what she did
one of the core characteristics of all
semiconductor companies is the tick tock
model
this is when companies switch between
improving the chip itself to improving
the manufacturing process
improvements to both of these are
crucial in producing more powerful chips
but companies will never attempt to do
both of them at the same time
doing both at the same time makes
troubleshooting errors extremely
difficult because the error could be due
to the new manufacturing process or due
to the new chip despite this lisa chose
to ditch the tick tock model and just
try to improve both sides at the same
time
for years we had little idea as to how
well this process was going but when
ryzen and epic were launched in 2017 it
was clear that amd had hit it out of the
park amd had not only caught up the
intel in terms of technology but they
had actually outdone them especially in
terms of multitasking for the same price
ryzen offered significantly more cores
and threads than intel now of course
each of these cores were less powerful
than intel's but for many tasks to
streaming having more cores was
preferable to having fewer more powerful
cores and amd was just getting started
lisa's goal wasn't just to beat intel
but to leave them in the dust and that's
exactly what they've done
one of the clear signs of this was how
quickly amd was able to transition to
the next architecture
if you're not familiar with chips
they're usually classified by a size
such as 7 nanometers or 10 nanometers
which is indicative of their fabrication
process
the long-term goal is to make these
chips as small as possible and let's
just say amd smoked intel to 10
nanometer chips amd launched their seven
nanometer architecture 3000 series chips
in mid-2019 meanwhile intel didn't
complete their transition to 10
nanometers till early 2021. now it
should be noted that amd7 nanometer
architecture is roughly equivalent to
intel's 10 nanometer architecture but
this still means that amd beat intel to
market by roughly 18 months
all of this has made amd the top choice
for desktop users in fact amd overtook
intel in terms of desktop cpu market
share in early 2021 and at this point
the only reason intel is still hanging
on is because they have so many deals
with laptop and pc makers and gamers
still often prefer intel due to superior
single core performance but if intel
doesn't make moves against amd right now
it's likely that this market will slowly
dissipate as well
the rise of the mobile market and stiff
competition from amd were no doubt major
external threats to intel's business but
honestly amd likely wouldn't have been
able to catch up and even humiliate
intel if intel was on top of their game
i mean if you want proof just take a
look at the gpu market lisa has advanced
amd exponentially within the gpu space
as well but they still can't quite catch
up to nvidia now don't get me wrong here
amd gpus have become a solid option
especially from a price to performance
perspective however if we simply take a
look at the most powerful gpus on the
market there's no question that nvidia
is the clear winner and the key reason
for this is that nvidia and jensen huang
were always on their a-game so when amd
started throwing punches with the radeon
and vega gpus nvidia was well prepared
to fight back meanwhile intel was simply
caught off guard and one of the main
reasons for this is intel's leadership
crisis intel's leadership issues can be
traced back to 2005 when paul ortolini
took over paul was actually the first
ceo of intellect that was not an
engineer he had joined the company sales
and marketing division in 1974 and he
slowly worked his way up from there
paul's lacking engineering background
was actually a major concern when he
took over but he appeased much of the
skeptics with phenomenal revenue paul
was a master marketer and deal maker
which allowed intel to become more
dominant than ever before within a
desktop market with that being said
though it could be argued that paul's
lack of engineering experience resulted
in him making poor fundamental decisions
for the company for example he did not
embrace arm-based chips i feel that
someone with a technological background
like jensen wong or lisa sue would have
made this jump in a heartbeat but while
paul may have made some bad
technological moves at least he blew up
into his profits and revenue intel's
next ceo brian krasnich didn't do this
either
intel's revenue basically just went
sideways throughout all of his
leadership this makes sense as most of
brian's leadership was just filled with
playing out of the smartphone market the
worst part however was the drama that
brian brought with him you see it in
2018 it would be revealed that brian was
having an affair with an employee and
this would get him fired bob swan would
replace him at seo and unfortunately for
bob this was terrible timing he
inherited into all right as amd was
doubling down on ryzen which meant that
bob had to take all the heat from
falling behind
and it was under bob's leadership that
intel struggled to transition to 10
nanometer chips to make things even
worse it was under his leadership that
apple ditched intel as you would guess
bob didn't last very long and he was
quickly replaced by patrick gelsinger in
early 2021 fortunately patrick does have
a technical background and he's been
with intel for over 40 years so
hopefully he's the right person to turn
intel around but there's no doubt that
the last decade of intel's leadership
wasn't the most productive
looking forward intel isn't no risk of
going bankrupt they're still pulling in
tens of billions in profits every single
year but with that being said intel is
not in the best of positions either
they're no longer the dominant chip
player that they used to be and looking
forward it it seems more and more likely
that intel turns into something like
atnt cisco or ge
while these companies are massive
they're not exactly exciting or
innovative and in a fast-moving industry
such as semiconductors it's not clear
how long intel can just remain dormant
the rest of the industry has already
clipped intel several fold over the past
decade nvidia is currently worth two and
a half times intel and that's with
nvidia being down 50 from their all-time
high and earlier this year even amd
overtook intel in terms of market cap
which was unthinkable just five years
ago also let's not forget about the chip
shortage amd's profits grew 5x during
the shortage qualcomm's profits grew
forex during the shortage and nvidia's
profits grew 3x during the shortage
meanwhile intel's net income didn't even
move and if intel can't catch up during
a chip shortage it's unclear if they
ever will
at this point it seems like the best
case scenario for intel is to just
maintain their market share because the
days of intel dominance are long gone do
you think intel can recover comment that
down below also drop a like if you're
glad that amd introduced competition
into the market and of course consider
checking out our international channels
to watch your videos in other languages
and consider subscribing see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hurry and i'll see you guys on
the next one